incredibly corrupt
the whole system is yeah let me just
tell you about the drug war
today i'm not talking about but done a
policeman gets a
job here in any town there's a 10 or 15
of them going this year
and one of them he's a go-getter and he
lets his hair grow
and he gets some tattoos and some dirty
clothes and he goes under the bridge
and he gets one of those poor mental
mentally ill people
bombs hobos and they sell two or three
or five grams to their neighbor over
there and he arrests both of them
federally now he's got two and next
month he does it
and he's got two more in the end of the
year he's got 15 or 20
major drug busts and he does that for
two or three years
and uh the other fellow he's he's at a
death somewhere
and this guy mates captain
this guy's a captain that got the desk
one no the one the one that makes all
these little tiny busts
all these insignificant nothing he's
just putting four people in prison
right now he's captain now he's
lieutenant now he's captain now he's he
goes up the ladder
rocket now the prosecutor the one that
can say i got him i got him he has two
grams of
methamphetamine two grams ladies and
gentlemen of the jury he has five
give him five years in prison no matter
about his poor wife and children crying
give him put him in prison we need we
need father for this
for these private prisons and for the
federal system oh boy
we got him and if i'm a prosecutor and i
get enough convictions
i got a 98 conviction rate i'm gonna
make judge
and i'll never lose my job at five
hundred thousand dollars a year
it's all about climbing the line yes
climbing the ladder and making money
wow yeah exactly how it works that
judicial system
is just so so corrupt
are you familiar with the story of um
uh ross albrecht no
he's uh he was a kid he was in his early
30s when he got busted he got like
two life sentences for
uh he started this website it's like a
it was it's called silk road it was
basically like
this dark web um place where people can
go buy
any kind of drugs they want so it's like
an online marketplace for people to buy
anything they want
as long as it didn't like the only rules
were you can't harm people or you can't
like
you can't order people to get murdered
or you can't
there's no human trafficking allowed but
it was mainly used for drugs so you
could buy any kind of drugs that you
wanted online
and it was kept anonymous like each all
the buyers and sellers were protected
because they used this form of currency
called bitcoin
which is a cryptocurrency and it's it's
easily you can easily keep
the people making the transactions
anonymous and he was just
created a website basically that anyone
could go on there and make a transaction
and he took a small fee
and he ended up getting two life
sentences
because he didn't take the deal they off
they obviously offered him a really big
um a really big plea deal and he didn't
take it they thought he could beat it
and
there was a bunch of corrupt corrupt
agents involved in his case
and the kid got the kid got basically he
got
double the sentence that el chapo got
and he was just some 20 year old kid
that made a website an ecommerce website
that's i mean that story really hit home
for me
as far as exposing like the real issues
of the
judicial system in this country and they
made a documentary about it and
it's just disgusting it's sick it's
disgusting vomiting sick on the floor
i mean here i am i serve 33 years mostly
for marijuana and i walk out and big
billboards
relax we deliver your marijuana to your
house
it's just like in the prohibition those
guys got 12 years in alcatraz
for making whiskey they went when they
got out and the law was passed the next
year
yes but you broke the law then you got
to stay
and after 12 years they walk out of
alcatraz and walk across the street and
get them a drink out of the bar
right that's the same thing's happening
it's insane man it's stupid
i mean president jimmy carter had it all
most of the prison
a great portion of the prison is from
mentally
incapacitated or people that are
somewhat have some problems
they had problems from probably their
early childhood they were unwanted
unloved
orphanage foster home beaten
abused men and women and they come to
prisons
and they treat other people that way we
need help for these people it's a
selfish it's a
it's a social issue it's an issue that
society owes to the people that
we have here is there any country that's
doing it right
like obviously we're doing it worse than
anybody we have more people locked up
per capita than any other country in the
world right
is that is there anybody who who's doing
this right is anything we could take
from
another country and learn from them i
understand portugal
my country oh holland holland holland
absolutely holland's great at it
and and didn't holland legalize like uh
heroin or something
i don't know exactly what they did where
you can you can go i heard that you that
if you uh if you're addicted to heroin
or you want to if you want to use heroin
you can actually go to a doctor
and they'll give you like a clean needle
and they'll give you like a oh yes
that's been
a long time there and uh even birmingham
england does it and they got proof
listen the people clean up the
prostitutes clean up the people get a
job
but america goes into birmingham and
says you can't do that you can't set a
precedent like this
we must have our prisons full
so they fight so hard the american
judicial system the dea they won't they
want this stuff to go on
it's wrong i mean it's wrong in the
eyes of man and god it's just wrong they
take these people and
take them away from their children their
families and their take their homes
i mean they work for forever inherited
from their grandmother
they just you better believe if they
some money in it they're there to get it
so it's just wrong do you think it'll
ever change
what do you think there's a course is
going to change it can't be that's
already swung hard the other way now
it's just got to it's just what's the
answer like how
like what kind of what sort of steps do
you think it's
have to take to make this be a healthy
issue if a guy's got
a heroin addict let's just say heroin
egg
they know right now that this craton
if they will take those tablets they
have no withdrawal whatsoever
but the uh federal drug administration
tried them correct them yeah they fight
it hard they don't want it
right it's just like the marijuana oil
relieving all these pains
they don't want it they fight it hard
and they pay their politicians
they got lobbyists walking the halls of
congress you get trips and you get money
and you can do anything for you
we got big pharmaceutical companies that
produce pills but we got oxycontin
we got well we got vicodin you got to go
get go to the doctor and get a
prescription to some opiates yeah that's
the answer yeah
not this unregulated stuff exactly so
they
it but it's coming to light it's slowly
slowly slowly coming to light that
this is this is wrong it is
it's it's it's terrifying and then
another thing is is parenting i feel
like
parenting is is so important and a lot
of the people that end up in prisons a
lot of people that end up in the streets
homeless
addicted to drugs it seems like the
the catalyst the one thing the most the
one common denominator across
all these people is is messed up
childhoods
and absolutely and parents that weren't
prepared for children
my mantra is that
a couple should have a permit before
they have a baby
that might be mean but a little sparrow
builds her nest before she lays an egg
the problem is how the problem is you
can't stop them from having babies
though right
stop them but you you have to perm have
to have a permit to ride a moped on the
streets of america
right how much more important is to
bring a child into it my daughter who's
a doctor she delivered a baby
to an 11 year old child your daughter
delivered a baby
from 11 year old child four generations
in the waiting room all on welfare
wow 12 14 youngins that's the problem is
even if you put in a law like that
people are still going to breed people
are still going to have babies i don't
say they wouldn't but i'm just saying
that's the answer to it to educate
people to encourage people to
have a mother and a father have a home
have a living have some get babies we
want
instead of babies that we're just going
to get for the welfare check
that's awful to encourage the wrong
people to have babies
should he encourage the right people to
have babies
i don't know the answers roger i don't
think we have them but anyhow
that's the question now and that gets
the answer it is the question it's a
very hard question
how are you going to do it it's a very
dicey
it's a very dicey subject and it's it's
so